so you remember in the past we did um
we've done two really big numbers in
particular in the past we did graham's
number and tree three right so if you
remember tree three was this number that
was that was so big that
you know even just to prove that it was
finite there just wasn't enough time
left in the universe to do that you
would have a universe would reset itself
before you ever got to complete the
proof it's it's just stupid it's it's
just
you can't even picture it and graham was
so big that if you thought about it your
head would collapse to form a black hole
so these are two really crazy numbers
but what i really want to talk about
today is kind of sort of crazy of crazy
i want to talk about
a number which combines both and that's
tree of graham's number i'm worried the
universe is going to collapse on us well
you know
we need to worry about that as you might
remember from from those original videos
both
tree three and graham's number they both
arise in sort of a sequence particularly
let's remind ourselves where graham's
number came from sort of very briefly to
get to graham's number we started out
with something which i'll call g1
which was three
arrow arrow arrow ro3 right now this was
a really big number now just to remind
you what these arrows were if i have 3
arrows 3
that just means 3 to the 3. it's a fancy
way of writing 3 to the power 3 which is
of course 27. if i take a double arrow
well that just means doing a repetition
of the single arrow in this case three
times that would be
three
arrow
three arrow three
which is three
to arrow
27 which is about 7.6
trillion i think it is
okay and then if you had three arrows
well that's just repeated double arrows
okay
so that's just repeat repetition of the
double arrow so that's three
to the
three to the three
which is again three double arrows seven
point six trillion
which is basically a power tower of
three so three to the three to the three
to the three and so on that is seven
point six trillion high okay so this is
just stupidly big numbers and actually
the first sort of rung on the ladder of
graham's graham's little graham sequence
is actually has four arrows so it's a
repetition of three arrows so this is
the first point on graham sequence but
then you go up right
graham what ron graham told us to do was
actually to sort of build this sequence
up you would then go to g2 where the
number of arrows itself was already this
huge number
okay so you actually now have g1 arrows
and the arrows as you can see from this
make numbers really really big so
actually now when we start putting
really big numbers in the number of
arrows we get crazy big and he carried
on with this sequence until he got to
g64
which was this graham's number
so you have this sequence one you can
start for this g1 g2 until all the way
up to g64 and you can carry on right
this defines a sequence which you could
call gn which is basically related to
the one before
by taking the number of arrows that you
had before so you relate it like that so
this defines the sequence
the tree trees also gave us a sequence
now if you remember from that video the
trees are basically this idea of you you
play a game with it with a finite number
of seeds different types of seeds and
you try to grow trees and and the idea
is how long can this game go on for so
if you have one type of seed
then the game can last a maximum
of basically one go so tree one is one
tree two so if you have two different
seeds
is um is three
and then if you have three different
seeds
then the game literally goes on for can
potentially go on for absolutely ages
this number is massive
okay it's a really really big number
like it's actually bigger than grams but
that's what i told you okay so we're
going to think a bit more about that but
this is a truly truly gargantuan number
and but of course you could carry on
with this sequence you could try tree 4
3 5 3 6 in general some tree n
and you could even think of course about
tree of graham's number
so that's what we want to think about
now
that we have two sequences here right
and the real question i want to ask is
is which sequence
is better so let's ask this question let
me let me write down
[Music]
so we've got these two sequences we've
got tree of n and we've got g of n so
we've got the trees and the g's okay and
we can build this number tree of
graham's number right which is basically
tree
of g of 64. but i could also think about
going the other way around what i mean
by that i mean do the trees first and
then
do the g's so in other words i'm going
to start playing the game of trees first
and then i climb graham's ladder so what
do i mean by that i mean take tree
in this case of 64.
and then
evaluate that in graham sequence so i'm
doing it the other way around so here
i'm climbing grain ladder first 64 rungs
and then i'm playing the game of trees
here i'm playing the game of trees with
64
you know sort of seeds and then i'm
climbing grain bladder
so which of these numbers is bigger
okay which is bigger oh
can i have a guess go on
i got the impression from you in the
previous videos that trees are more
powerful
so i'm gonna say
that one's bigger but that's got tree in
it as well
yeah but it's you're giving the tree
less juice there you're only giving the
tree 64 juice and there you're giving
the tree graham's number juice i think
that's a beautiful way to put it
actually brady and you are right okay
but let's let's actually explore this a
little bit more let's do it with a much
simpler simpler pair of sequences which
are basically just powers so i can
imagine a sequence where p to the n is
two to the n so basically take take the
um two to the to the power of whatever
number i'm interested in and quadratics
okay so basically take n if you give me
n i give you n squared these are two
different sequences neither of these are
anywhere near as powerful as tree or g
but they'll illustrate the point now as
you would put it in this case the
exponent you know this one has more
juice okay this is more powerful than a
quadratic exponents grow more quickly
than quadratics in this case we can
study and ask which is it better to do
first or last okay which is going to
take us to the bigger place let's look
at this and let's let's start with maybe
n equals one
okay so if we do q first we take the
quadratic of one okay that gives me one
and then i have to do p which is going
to take me to two okay so i'll get two
if i do the other way around so i'm
going to start with one i then need to
take its power that's going to give me
two and then i need to take the
quadratic so that's going to give me
four
okay
so you can see if i do for n equals one
actually
doing this guy last actually seems to
win okay that doesn't feel quite right
let's try a bigger number let's do n
equals three so if i take the quadratic
first that takes three to nine and then
i take the power
okay that takes that gets me to two to
the nine which i think
is 512. quite a big number now let's do
the other way around okay so we start
with three we take the power so that's
two to the three which is eight
and then we take the quadratic
64. so you can see here the minute we
went to a slightly bigger number
actually
it was indeed advantageous to do the big
guy last okay and actually as long as
you take n bigger than two
it's always going to be better to do the
big guy last so it is it is true you're
right ready the big guy the most
powerful guy is the one that you should
do last if you want to get some really
really big numbers so now let's go back
to tree and g now you your intuition
says that tree is bigger
that's correct but what's the
mathematical way of of sort of of
measuring that is there a mathematical
measure for that sort of thing for how
fast a sequence grows okay just is there
a measure of how fast tree n grows is
there a measure for how fast gn grows or
any other sequence okay and there is
and for these growing sequences the
thing that we use is something called
the the fast growing hierarchies so
we're going to start off with a very
with a sort of function that does grow
but it doesn't grow very quickly okay so
really really start off with basics and
that's the successor function so this is
a very simple guy it's basically just
says take n and go to the next one along
it's counting basically it's the first
thing you learn at school right so two
goes to three three goes to four and so
on right so it's growing fun it's a
growing sequence it just doesn't grow
very quickly okay but this is this
successor function is the basic for
basis for all the it's the seed for all
these fast growing hierarchies okay so i
want something gross obviously this
doesn't grow as fast as tree or g i
think we can agree that right okay so
let's try and get something that grows a
bit faster but this is the seed for
everything else so what can grow a bit
faster well you define f of one
okay which is defined as doing this guy
n times
okay so i'm going to do f
lots of times
in fact i'm going to do it n times on n
okay so what is this so another way of
writing that is just f
0 to the n of n so what am i really
doing here i'm doing i'm adding 1
to n
n times
where's that going to take me that's
going to take me to 2n
two times n
yeah i'm adding and n so n two i'm
adding one to n n times that's gonna
take me to it
okay so you can see this is already
growing more quickly this one was just
adding one each time this one is now
doubling it's not a much faster ground
function but it is a faster ground
function than the successor guy okay and
we've done it back we've built it from
that successor seed okay so let's carry
on let's try f2 we're going to define it
the same way we're basically going to
say do f1
n times
on m
okay
so what's this going to give me well
this is basically saying
multiply by 2 n
times so that's going to give me 2 to
the n
times n
so now we've gone to an exponent
okay so we've gone from successors
to multiplication so it's like by doing
repeating repeated succession to
exponentiation by doing repeated
multiplication i can carry on okay
what's the next guy
well that basically says do this and end
number of times so what's that going to
give me well i don't want to write it
down this is going to be something
that's more like the double arrow this
is actually going to grow more quickly
than that guy just slightly but it's the
same similar sort of you know sort of
growth rate but but slightly more more
quickly than that okay so this is what
we call tetration so you've got
successor
multiplication exponentiation this is
now tetration and i could carry this on
okay i could just carry on defining it
the same way by repetition of the one
before
next one would be pentation
and hexation and so on and so on and so
forth okay and i could do loads of these
right and i could the whole time one for
every integer right all the way up okay
great
now
this gives me a hierarchy for this gives
me a measure for how fast functions grow
i can measure them against these guys so
you could have f a hundred f of a
hundred f of a google f f f f graham's
number even right okay and my question
is is do these numbers grow faster or
which where where does where does the g
sequence and the tree signals appear in
this in this hierarchy is it faster than
some of them i'm not others you know
okay
what do you think
i know you've got a cheeky smile so i
think you're about to i think you're
about to pull something on me here
i don't know i mean presumably because
this f thing
is in infinite could
just keeps growing it must get to a
point at some point where i can use it
to
so that's a good point so it's certainly
true that for a given value of n so if i
put say
you know i don't know some large value
of n in here i could get a number that
was bigger than graham's number but
that's not what i'm asking i'm asking do
these sequences
do any of them grow more quickly than
graham sequence or the tree sequence so
for the same value of n are they going
to give me bigger numbers
i feel like
you must be able to get there because
because the way the way tree works and
the way graeme works is like
set in stone
whereas this thing you can just keep
making bigger and bigger until you until
it it's fit for purpose the answer is no
none of these even if i carried on all
the way
through all the integers for all the
natural numbers there's never going to
be a sequence that's as fast as either
g the g sequence or the tree sequence
they're both faster
so they're both of the tree and the g
they grow quicker than any of these
any of these and that's like whoa that's
what i'm gonna do now okay so how can i
measure them well
the problem is is that you're just
dealing with finites okay look at what
we have here
what have we built up here so i kind of
i think i need another sheet
[Music]
yeah so you can see with that with that
sequence of functions i had f0 f1 f2
right they all had an index zero next
one was one next one was two and three
and so on right and in principle i could
have had any any natural number okay
arbitrarily large but i was restricted
to the natural numbers
okay i can go one beyond i can go to
infinity what comes after these numbers
well there's also something important to
distinguish about these numbers is that
they had an order okay there was there
they were you know i have a notion of
hierarchy f naught doesn't grow as fast
as f1 doesn't grow as fast as f2 and so
on the the indices were important that
they they came in order so you can
really think of these numbers these
indices as more like ordinals rather
than cardinal numbers cardinal numbers
tell you how much
ordinal numbers add a bit of order to
that they add you know it's first second
third and so on once you've you know
you've gone all the way through the
natural numbers where'd you go next well
infinity right so i can talk about
infinity which i just i write as the
ordinal infinity i write as an omega and
that's basically defined as the thing
that comes after
all the others all these all these
finite ordinals the thing that comes
after is ordinal infinity so that gives
me a way to climb a bit higher so i'm
going to define a new
type of function
okay that's labeled by this guy
now how am i going to do that so i'm
just going to draw some of the f's that
we've already already created okay so
let me just draw a few of them so f1 of
one okay
f1 of two
two one f2
okay so here are some of the some of the
f's that we've we could carry on right
in all directions where you've put an
integer in the in the place of the n
yeah yeah exactly i'm actually going to
look at the values now okay so you know
if i go along this way i i'm sort of
changing the argument increasing the
arguments if i go this way i'm
increasing the index okay so let's just
plug in some values for what these guys
are this is two four this is six so
indeed i i grow as i grow that way that
was a that was a doubling so this guy is
two this guy is eight this guy is
twenty-four this guy's two
this guy is two oh four eight bigger
number this next guy i'm not gonna write
it out because it has 121 million digits
wow this guy is huge then escalated
quickly i did that did escalate quickly
as as
they run wrong
so this has gone out of control quite
quickly the amazing thing is you're only
at f3 here
that escalated really quickly f can go
like to the millions and you still say
we're nowhere near the power we need to
deal with
graham's number very very true right but
let's let but what i want to do is i
want to create create an f so like which
i'm going to label with omega that grows
more quickly than anything that's gone
before
so how do i do that okay well what's the
quickest way i can grow in this picture
if i start out over here what's the
quickest way to grow
straight along the diagonal yeah right
you go straight along if you go this way
you get well look in two steps you're
suddenly 121 million digits if i went to
the next step
and i went to f4 of four then i think
this guy's somewhere between ten three
arrows four and ten three arrows
five it's in that interval
okay so going along the diagonal gets
you really big really quickly in fact
it's much more fast growing than
anything that went before
okay so that's what we're going to call
f omega something the base of the guy
that picks out the growth along the
diagonal so we can define that so we
just write that as
f
of omega of n we're going to define
as f of n
of n that's basically saying pick out
the diagonal so this would be the first
position second third already 121
million digits fourth already this
stupidness all the way down there we're
just going to get crazy we're going to
get a really really fast growing
function
okay now what kind of function is is
this going to look like well actually
you can show that this
is kind of generally going to be greater
than something that goes like this where
you've got n minus 1 arrows so this is
like kind of building up the arrows
which might sound like something that
we've done before
which was how we built graham's number
it built up the arrows you know the
index kind of went on the arrow which
made you get really really big that's
why these other functions these these
guys
were never able to do as well as graham
okay because they weren't really hitting
the index on the arrow okay the arrow
put it on the arrow makes it grow much
more quickly so this guy's doing it it's
doing much better okay we can talk about
next ordinal the one after oh we go okay
the one after infinity that's kind of
weird i'm just gonna call it
get plus one
right now you might say what what on
earth is that that's clearly nonsense
right you're talking about infinity plus
one well there's an infinity plus one
just infinity that's not really true
when you're talking about ordinals
depending on how you define it what i
really mean by this i mean the thing
that comes after what went before what
comes after omega okay so by definition
it's not the same thing okay you can't
really do that with the cardinals but
you can with ordinals because the order
matters okay so i can quite reliably
talk about something that is that just
comes after this this ordinal infinity
it's the next one along how do i get
that well i already know how to add one
to my sequence of fast-growing functions
i just do it the usual way right i do f
of omega plus one is just an application
of this guy
n times
okay so it's f of omega
n
n
now this is starting to terrify me now
because look how fast this guy grew this
was this was this was growing with
reporting makes the index indices going
on the arrows this guy has just gone off
on one now this is even faster than that
this is this is mad i don't even want to
yeah i think you could you can relate
this to these conway chains
but um
i don't even want to go there about how
big this is great but i don't need to
stop
okay i could carry on right i could
carry on i could just go let me get plus
two
and so on right i could keep going i
could keep defining these functions this
way right eventually i would run out of
things to add what do i do then well i
just add omega
okay
so i would define an omega this the
limit of this i would then add something
on top of that which was this which i
call omega 2
which is kind of next level of ordinals
okay but i don't need to stop then i can
carry on i can do omega two plus one and
all the while i'm defining new functions
this way
okay omega omega two plus two and keep
going until eventually i run out of
finite numbers to add and then i just
say oh next one is going to be omega 2
plus omega which i'm going to call omega
times three
okay but now look what i've got so all
the wireless functions that are coming
along for the ride they're just going
mad right now so what's next okay so so
look what i've built now i've managed to
get well there's like an omega times one
which is just omega i've also got omega
times two
and omega times three
okay so i can start building this
sequence up as well
okay just by doing these these repeated
additions okay well eventually i'm going
to run out what do i do then well i say
the next one along is omega times omega
which is omega squared
okay so i can talk about a function
which is growing like f of omega squared
which is i
don't even know what it is right it's
mad it's just going to be something
crazy i can carry on building these
omegas omega to the omega oh we get to
the um we get to the omega omega to the
omega to the omega to the omega d
until i run out well what do i do then
okay well then there's another ordinal
which you call
epsilon naught which is kind of like an
ordinal infinity that's just whoa it's
just way out there way bigger than this
guy way bigger than any of these and
there's a there's a there's a growing
function which is labeled by that as
well it's a doesn't mean they're
thinking about how fast that grows
okay you can carry on there's a whole
system of that you can play with this
play with this sort of technology all
the way you have it cylon you can define
epsilon naught you can build up more and
more epsilon one
you can even start talking about cylon
with an index which is epsilon north
itself and then you can have another
index which is epsilon epsilon naught
and you can grow grow grow grow grow
your next thing is it's called the next
one is called sorry
uh a zeta number and then there's an eta
number and then eventually you just keep
going and use these these things called
veblen hierarchies and all this and then
eventually you get to a point where
you've got something which is just off
the scale
massive ordinal which is called
gamma zero it's called the fefferman
shoot ordinal it's the largest thing
that you can create using these kind of
recursion methods and this thing called
feven hierarchy which we're going to go
into
the point is is f's that can come along
for the ride does it even bear thinking
about what f of gamma zero grows like
okay this is a crazily fast growing
function right i mean look full just it
it was so far away we didn't we didn't
even bother to describe it right okay so
back to the million dollar question
or the three three dollar question
okay where does where does the g
sequence the graham sequence and the
tree sequence lie
in all of this so what what f what
function do we build that's going to
keep pace with true exactly which which
of these f's can keep pace with either g
or tree
okay
let me tell you
let's do a g first
g we can handle okay
g doesn't grow as fast as f omega plus
one it doesn't grow as fast as that you
can kind of see why right already at f
of omega we're starting to see the the
sort of index appearing on the arrows
which is kind of like how graves number
is built okay so graham's sequence and
grows
doesn't grow any faster than this guy
okay what about
tree tree grows faster than this it
grows faster
it even grows faster than this guy
tree grows faster than this
so none of these guys can handle tree
the tree sequence grows faster than all
of them now
you can go beyond gamma zero if you want
to it all gets really quite messy so
we're not going to go there safe to say
that tree is off the scale fast growing
even faster than this guy whereas we
could handle g so the answer to the
original question was that yes indeed
tree does have a lot more juice than g
so tree of graham's number is bigger
than graham of tree essentially
if you'd like some more from this
interview or maybe you'd like to watch
some more videos about really big
numbers
or you'd like to learn more about trees
check out the links on the screen and
down in the video description there's
some stuff there we'd love you to see